Here's a great example of the potential
of quality reporting to add
transparency to healthcare through
public reporting of quality metrics.
Suppose you have diabetes and
want to make sure your provider
cares for it properly.
Where would you go to find that out?
In general there's no good answer, but
in Indiana many providers voluntarily
report their data at the practice level.
Here it is for
the Hemoglobin A1c process metric.
Remember, that means doing the test
periodically as recommended.
Three of the practices are below the
standard for the state, as shown in red.
Two are below their regional average,
as shown in green.